hey what's going on guys welcome to
today I may have mentioned before that
I've been redoing my house a little bit
nothing too crazy just updating some
rooms and trying to organize that's the
big thing so I had somebody come in and
help me her name is Jen and she's been
incredible I will do a separate video on
that but right now you still so cute my
parents are on their way here and today
a lot of stuff is coming I have
furniture being delivered I have a mover
coming to help me move some things
around but no one is here right now and
I have to do this now because I need to
air out this rug that I bought a long
time ago it's in my garage all of this
stuff is either being donated or sold
the carpet is all the way over here so I
gotta get this out of here and all the
way outside so that it can air out for a
little while because it's been in the
garage for a while don't know what's
gonna happen I might die today
[Music]
look at this confused dog my succulents
are looking wonderful no many I have
doing something
[Music]
hey this room finally has been painted
the furniture that's being delivered
today will go here here and here this
room is gonna be a guest room but I'm
getting a couch so it'll be a pull-out
couch which is where I'll be sleeping
for this week
I'm gonna get a nice desk here this is
all done being painted a nice white but
you can't really tell what is the
weather what I need to know my dad is
chilly you're taking the family out
we're gonna go for like a little Drive I
got to get some things that Bath and
Beyond and I'm gonna be using my coupon
do you have a coupon I just got three
coupons in the mail is gonna bring for
you and I forgot them oh yeah look at
this gram watch this there's a new part
yeah but this goes here there's a cart
nope buh-bye we made it to Bed Bath &
Beyond and this is just the most
incredible invention ever my grandma's
like do you go with it I'm like I wish
they'd be still great if I could ride
with it come on let's go buddy you're my
friend you're my friend comfy I'm off to
get a haircut
my hair done okay that's good I'll burn
the beer we're having fun there's the
fam and I really want to play basketball
I stole this $20 Jenn I'll get it
I'll be back
really bad we gotta go find it we gotta
go find something
hey basketball
look at you if Jenna's birthday today so
right now I'm heading to pick up her
cake we got mom we got grandma we got
dad taking a nap we're gonna go pick up
the cake and then pick up dad and we're
gonna go visit Jenna get some brunch
maybe go to the do gparc a so generously
know exactly what this cake is because I
asked her to send me the picture right
before I ordered and she said are you
getting this on my cake I'm like no yes
I am
top tier treats I changed the name I
needed no to something on my nose I used
a charcoal nose peel and guess what it
did ripped off the skin on my weight
especially about taking that into the
dog park
I enjoyed my breakfast so much today
we're gonna be eating dinner in like
four hours hopefully I'll be ready to
eat yeah just the best birthday ever
[Music]
today what could it be
let's cut this cake we are back here at
Malibu wines Safari candy once before it
is pretty much the coolest experience
ever you basically hop on this trap and
you take a really cool tour of their
vineyard and you get to meet Stanley
Stanley is an extremely famous travel
he's doing The Hangover
and he giraffe you see in movies that's
probably Stanley this is super cute I
look so dumb in that like you're a liar
you should pull it all the way down tip
4 oh well we're gonna go seize family
getting that alone that's pretty that is
great
[Music]
does feel more like it tickles a him
with his Stanley so cool five mr.
Stanley this is Stanley's little house
it's so tall his family's all by family
see you later bye
so this Rosa is very nice it's got even
fun - strawberry juice to it the first
time you're going to be drinking is our
sparkling rosette
[Music]
oh my god keep on massive Oh God
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
today we're at the Getty Museum and I'm
so excited because I've lived in Los
Angeles for about eleven years and I've
always wanted to come here so today we
decided that the day is today that we go
it's a day hufa day
hi dad we got the whole fam here we got
mom we got to have got Graham and we're
gonna go see some things the heatwave is
real they've been talking about this
heatwave for about a week and it's
finally hit it's so hot
[Applause]
[Music]
it's got a little map let's see I've
never been here so I really don't even
know what to do so start your visit
here's where we really gotta get to
where deep that can sleep under the
stars become sleep under the stars under
the stars
this is an incredible view of Los
Angeles can pretty much see well I'd say
you can see everything but there's huge
a mountain kind of blocking everything
it's
we can do what we like like baby while
we
[Music]
let's make the most of this night come
on baby take my hand and we don't need
to do the things we don't that's it we
had a fun quick trip to the Getty Museum
I definitely wanna come back and look at
some more of the paintings it is so hot
outside like can't really fully enjoy
the garden because it is so hot I've got
a mint that's really good over here son
over here we've got a you so much fun in
LA doing all kinds of fun little
festivities and that's gonna bring this
vlog to a close this is pretty much what
I've been doing for the past week with
my family I haven't blogged everything
but I figured I would just film a couple
fun little Clips here and there yeah
I'll leave you guys this beautiful
sunset and I will see you later
[Music]